so the question is what would actually
happen to your body if you really gave
up sugar I mean completely for two weeks
let's take a look at that number one you
are gonna lose your appetite to sugar
why because every time you consume sugar
a hormone comes in there and pushes your
blood sugars down causing a low blood
sugar situation hypoglycemia
to some degree and that is going to
cause you to crave sugar so by getting
rid of sugar you get rid of the craving
for sugar number two you're gonna be
less hungry until you do this you won't
really fully know but I'm telling you
it's the sugar that keeps you hungry all
the time when you give up the sugar you
become a lot less hungry why because you
stabilize your blood sugars and now your
cells can be actually fed because when
you're living in sugar because the sugar
is toxic to the body the body starts
rejecting it that's called insulin
resistance so the body is blocking
insulin because that controls sugar and
what your body's really trying to do is
limit the amount of sugar inside the
cells so the body doesn't consider it a
good thing it's a bad thing so when you
give it up this thing could reverse and
not only can you now absorb proper
amounts of fuel you'll absorb nutrients
a lot better too because insulin
resistance also blocks nutrients
minerals vitamins and that's one of the
functions of insulin alright number
three you're gonna have less fatigue
especially after eating a meal when
you're eating sugar on a regular basis
usually you're gonna be tired after you
eat and that is a blood sugar thing but
you're gonna find that you're no longer
gonna be that tired after you eat it
just means that now you're no longer
having higher sugar which basically
makes the brain tired it's normal sugar
and now your brain can be awake alright
number four you're gonna lose excessive
water and fat for the first week you're
gonna dump a lot of water in some fat
but after that it's going to be more and
more fun you're going to be surprised
how much fluid you were retaining
some people within one week can lose
about 13 pounds of fluid they're holding
that fluid around and that can't be that
healthy for the heart of course you're
gonna see your your clothes loosening
especially on the midsection your gut
your waist is one of the best indicators
to tell if you're doing too much sugar
if you reduce the sugar the stomach
shrinks if you eat the sugar your
stomach will expand okay number five
enhanced mood so if you were grouchy
before you're now gonna be a lot calmer
less stressed and you're gonna be
actually nice to be around okay that's
good also your cognitive function will
improve so you're you're gonna feel more
focused you can have more concentration
you'll be less a DD more attention to
focus on your projects okay number six
your skin is gonna look much better
you're gonna have less acne your skin's
gonna glow and that's just a reflection
of what happens when you consume sugar
your insulin goes up and also the
hormone androgens and we're talking
about females antigen will go up and
that's gonna create acne in a male body
the increased insulin will lower
testosterone so you're gonna have other
problems that are associated with low
testosterone alright number seven you
have less stiffness so you're gonna have
less inflammation you're gonna have less
pain so what's happening is all we're
doing is we're converting your fuel from
sugar to fat it takes three days okay
of cutting down the carbohydrates and
the sugar you may have a worsening of
the symptoms for three days okay guys
anyone can actually handle three days
and if you took some B vitamins from
nutritional yeast and some potassium you
probably won't have any symptoms so it's
going to be relatively easy at the
cellular level you're building new
enzymes to run your body off fat fuel
okay that's what's happening here you
have little machines that are literally
changing over to a different fuel source
that's what's happening over these two
weeks you're getting decrease
inflammation in your arteries okay
that's what's happening
when you get off sugar less inflammation
it's going to help you the long run
prevent a clot or plaquing and help
reduce the risk of a stroke and a heart
attack
also you'll start growing brain cells
why because when you reduce sugar then
you run your body and a different source
of fuel called ketones and ketones
support the growth of nerve cells
alright next one the liver
you're gonna start dumping some of this
fat that's been accumulating in your
liver and you can use that as fuel so
you're on your way to cleaning out the
liver so it's no longer fatty by the way
as a side note if you have a large belly
chances are you have a fatty liver okay
so by doing this you will reduce the fat
inside your liver and lastly you're
gonna have better kidney function take a
look at a diabetic the kidney is the
target for
problems when you actually cut down the
amount of sugar reduce the carb you can
improve kidney function greatly alright
guys there you have it you may want to
try this the proofs in the pudding maybe
I should talk about pudding but this is
the icing on the cake now maybe I should
even talk about that alright thanks for
watching
hey guys I'm not sure if you have my app
yet dr. Berg app it's totally free you
should download it okay this is what it
looks like you click it it gives you all
sorts of great resources I have all my
YouTube videos on this app okay and it's
regularly uploading the most recent ones
all the YouTube videos are also
converted to audio versions okay so you
can use it when you're walking
exercising driving your car I have a
mini course on there I'll be putting
additional courses I have a lot of
recipes on there this is new and also
PDF resources so there's various
downloads PDFs that you can get as well
and if you wouldn't mind after you
download it check it out give me your
unbiased review and tell me how you like
it I want to know